if I can experiment during college
McDonald's can experiment with flavors I
think it will taste like chocolate Oreo
ice cream with some coffee thrown in I
think it's going to be a cookie drink
for adults I think like all McDonald's
things it's going to be manufactured and
designed to like a seemingly fake level
of perfection we've got this cooking
magma kind of hanging out on top it does
kind of look like it could be cement but
I think that's just the Oreo flex
already looks too rich for me I could
have done without the crumbles on top oh
you got a crumb no no no or it does a
bit much I can taste the coffee a bit
more than I than I expected this is an
Oreo water it's super sweet heavy
refreshing it's like all all things that
are good there's no coffee in this I
call bull some great textures going on
in here it's like chewing good rocks
it's just so sweet the only way I can
drink this is like you know those little
hamster water dispensers right like dip
dip dip dip dip
look I commend McDonald's for for really
pushing the boundaries and trying stuff
but I feel like they have a long history
of doing things that they don't need to
do if they're gonna serve this for
breakfast and I want breakfast 24 hours
of McDonald's this has got hit written
all over it well that's alcohol yeah put
some alcohol there put some rum in there
make donald's after dark they can make
like a cookies and cream that's like
that total here's our hush the secret
agents at McDonald's like snuck into the
Starbucks laboratory I'm like we gotta
get all the frappe let's get all the
frappe recipes and then like the cops
came like they only got half the recipe